okay hi everybody again well we live in
unusual times and so I'm doing this
unusual thing of trying to answer
whatever questions you may come up with
about science
I've been studying and working on
science for most of my life and learnt a
few things so we'll see we'll see how I
do on answering your questions I did one
of these last week and this is kind of
back by popular request okay
gosh we've got questions already we've
got physics coming already all right I'm
going to do so got a couple of questions
here so let me let me start off Thomas
asking what are protons neutrons and
electrons made of okay well the story is
a bit different for so first of all
let's remember what where we where we
run into protons neutrons and electrons
so atoms are have a nucleus which
contains protons and neutrons and they
have electrons which are kind of sort of
orbiting outside the nucleus they're
kind of hanging around outside the
nucleus so it's a different story
electrons are a different kind of thing
than protons and neutrons in the
language of physics electrons are
examples of things called leptons and
protons and neutrons are examples of
things called baryons or hadrons those
are fancy words which probably get used
if you study physics in college or
graduate school and maybe don't get used
by anybody else um but there's sort of
two different families of kinds of
things okay so let's start off with
protons and neutrons so it was
discovered in the 1960s early 1960s that
protons and neutrons weren't just sort
of point things they were things that
have a definite structure inside and
actually they have they they're there
well they have a the diameter of a
proton is about 10 to the minus 15
meters which is otherwise known as
what's if I can do the conversion 1,000
trillionth of a meter so very small but
not zero so
what's inside protons and neutrons
inside protons and neutrons there are
things called quarks and that was kind
of quarks were originally person I knew
well actually kind of came up with that
idea back in the early 1960s that there
might be something inside protons and
neutrons so roughly inside protons and
neutrons each one of those has three
quarks inside it and like a proton has
two up quarks and a down quark and a
neutron has one up quark and two down
quarks and that's kind of what makes
those types of particles different is
they have different quarks inside them
now one of the tricky things is you
might say well why haven't I ever why
don't I have you know like why aren't
there bottles of quark surround why you
know protons neutrons are very common
why why do we not have quarks that we
can actually see well it's a very tricky
thing
so quarks are these little particles
which seem to be more or less point
particles they more or less have zero
size not quite we'll talk about that in
a minute but the question is why do they
never get out of protons and neutrons
and the answer is there are these things
called gluons which are another kind of
particle and between these these quarks
are kind of bound together by gluons
their goo ones that are being exchanged
between quarks and the gluons are
pulling very hard on these quarks and so
far as we can tell it's not possible to
get a quark outside of a proton or
neutron you can't ever pull it outside
so what happens roughly is this so if
you if you look at for instance some the
if you look at let's say the force of
gravity you might know as as
gravitational masses get further apart
the force of gravity between them goes
down it's actually an inverse square law
so if you so if the distance between the
objects is R the force between them is
is proportional to one over R squared
okay it's the same thing actually the
same exact force law for charged
particles particles that have electric
charge they also have a force law that
goes like 1 over R squared so as you
make them further and further apart but
force between them gets less and less
okay so gluons make a force between
hawks and the really weird thing is that
the force between quarks actually
instead of going down as you pull the
quarks apart it actually goes up it goes
up roughly roughly as the distance
between them is it goes up if the force
increases as you make the distance go up
it's roughly proportional to the to the
distance between the quarks the forces
so that means that you try and pull
these quarks apart it gets harder and
harder and harder to pull them apart so
if you try and actually get a quark all
the way out of a proton you can never do
it so so what's inside protons and
neutrons is this kind of soup of quarks
mainly three quarks and a bunch of
gluons that are holding these quarks
together it's a little bit confusing
there there's a whole kind of cloud of
quarks and antiquarks when you talk
about anti quarks and antimatter
different time but roughly it's it's the
sort of cloud of particles inside
protons and neutrons so that that's the
story about what's inside protons
neutrons so you might also ask well
what's inside quarks what's inside
gluons well the answer is nobody knows
you can ask the same question about
electrons as far as anybody can tell
electrons are perfect point particles
it's like they have no if you say what's
the radius of electron an electron what
people have always said in physics is
the radius of an electron is zero it is
like a perfect geometrical point now I
personally think that isn't correct and
actually I happen to have been very
recently working on kind of
understanding what might be sort of
underneath fundamental physics and I
actually think that in the end it's
going to turn out electrons are actually
not point particles they actually have a
size it's actually very very very small
but and they what's inside electrons I
think is related to kind of how space
works see space normally we think of
sort of the universe we say we can put
position things any way we want we can
say we put this electron at this
particular position if we specify by a
number it might be you know
position you know one point two three
seven five eight two four six four
cetera teller teller we could just go on
as many digits as we want we can
precisely say we're going to put this
electron at this precise place in space
I mean how we actually do that with an
experiment when might not be sure but at
least when we're doing theory of physics
we can say we put this electron at this
precise place okay well that would work
fine so long as space isn't it so long
as spaces itself continuous if space was
instead some grid where you could say oh
we can only put an electron at this
position on the grid or this other
position on the grid or this other
position you wouldn't be able to do this
thing of saying you can put it anywhere
you want well I actually think that in
the end it's going to turn out space it
isn't quite a grid it's more like a
network and in fact electrons correspond
to these kind of features of the network
it's kind of almost like little knots
where you have little little threads of
network that connect pieces of space and
electrons are kind of like little knots
in that network and in fact that that
means that in a sense when you say
what's inside an electron what's inside
an electron is a kind of space but a
funny kind of space but it's all that
that's I mean that's kind of a that's
that's physics that doesn't yet exist
because it's physics I've been working
on that there wasn't for this pandemic I
would be telling people much more about
the only way so that's that's kind of
the story of electrons is that the usual
theory in physics says there's nothing
inside electrons they just point
particles I think that isn't correct
there they actually have a small extent
and sort of what's inside them as a
special version of ordinary space same
with with quarks in ordinary in physics
as it's been thought about for the last
50 years or so it's the idea as quarks
are also point particles with nothing
inside them but again I don't think
that's correct okay long answer to that
term there question let me go back here
and I can also I might also say when you
start asking
about very small things like electrons
there are lots of tricky phenomena that
happen and maybe we'll talk about them
some more later about this thing called
quantum mechanics that kind of is all
about the fact that you can't when you
think you know where the electron is
maybe it isn't quite there you can't
quite localize it and so on long story
alright let's come to some other
questions here ok there's a question at
the beginning if neutron stars are just
made of neutrons how come they produce
light I don't think they usually produce
light they produce radio waves if they
produce so let me explain a little bit I
think I talked last time a little bit
about neutron stars so when a star
billions of years from now our Sun for
example will kind of run out of fuel and
it will just become a smaller a smaller
star but some other stars a bit more
massive than the Sun and can end up
having these giant supernova explosions
and what gets left over after that
explosion is often a neutron star which
is kind of something about the mass of
the Sun but compressed into something
maybe five miles across so it's a very
very dense object it's actually very
much like the nucleus of an atom except
very big like a five mile across atomic
nucleus all made of neutrons so the
question is how do you even know that
there's a neutron star there because
like a neutron it's just this big lump
of of stuff that is like an atomic
nucleus how would you know it's there
okay well turns out that so one of the
things that happens but this is some
complicated physics like we trying to
explain it so you probably know that the
earth has a magnetic field so that means
that's why compasses work so the earth
has a north and south magnetic pole it's
like it's like a giant bar magnet the
earth the earth acts like a giant bar
magnet and that's why a compass needle
can be can you know point towards the
North and South Poles and so the earth
the earth is kind of has this magnetic
field what produces the magnetic field
it's probably produced by essentially
electric currents in the liquid core of
the earth it's not completely clear how
that works and one of the things that's
weird is you think that the North
Magnetic Pole is to the north and it is
right now at the North Magnetic Pole is
somewhere in northern Canada right now
but over the course of history the
magnetic poles of the earth actually
move around and it's not been many
hundreds of years since they've been
actually in quite different positions
than they are now so that's probably
because of changes in the flow of the
kind of molten rock in the in the center
of the earth that's changing and causing
the magnetic field to be in a different
orientation but anyway so the earth has
a magnetic field the moon for example
does not have a magnetic field Jupiter
has a big magnetic field the Sun also
has a magnetic field and it's thought
that most stars have magnetic fields and
so that means that there are essentially
electric currents in the Sun that are
producing this magnetic field it's like
a giant bar magnet okay so what happens
is when when this star has a supernova
and it kind of compresses down to this
to this neutron star then the magnetic
field can't go away the magnetic field
has to be that it had when it was a big
sort of a large star is still there but
it has to be sort of compressed down to
kind of fit around this little tiny
neutron star and so then ends up with a
pretty intense magnetic field and so
what happens is this thing is like a bar
magnet a really quite strong bar magnet
and boy this is some complicated physics
okay so what happens is that electrons
spiral around the the magnetic field
lines of this bar magnet and the same
thing happens for the earth actually
there are electrons that come from the
Sun for example that spiral around in
the magnetic field of the earth near the
North and South Poles and so for example
that's what causes the aurora the aurora
you know if you go to the northern far
up north
and it's good weather and you let your
eyes get dark adapted and so on you'll
see this really cool it's usually red
green all kinds of other colors sort of
curtain like pattern in the sky that's
the aurora and that's produced by
electrons that originally came from the
Sun spiraling around the magnetic field
of the near the North Pole of the earth
and causing particularly things like
oxygen in the upper atmosphere of the
earth to to produce light of different
colors in kind of the same way that a
fluorescent light bulb produces light
it's sort of the same rough idea of how
light is produced in the upper
atmosphere and on aurora but anyway so
that's a place where you're producing in
that case it's producing light because
these electrons are hitting oxygen other
things in the upper atmosphere okay in a
in a with a neutron star electrons can
be can be kind of made they spiral
around and magnetic field and they
spiral around really quite fast and one
feature of electrons that are spiraling
around like that is they produce they
they emit radio waves and that's true in
general if you have you know when you
have a radio antenna the way the radio
antenna works is that it's making
electrons go up and down up and down up
and down a certain frequency like a
typical cell phone it might be 2 billion
times a second five billion times a
second that kind of that kind of thing
the electrons are going up and down up
and down in the antenna that's on the
side of your cell phone so it's the same
type of thing when electrons in magnetic
field of a neutron star going around
really fast and they're kind of being
made to go around in these circles and
that produces the same effect of making
radio waves that happens in something
like a cell phone but those radio waves
are pretty intense and we can
we can detect those radio waves even
though these neutron stars may be a
thousand light years away or really far
away across the across the galaxy and so
the the result of that is okay so I have
to explain one more thing gosh
I'm I don't get to explain this kind of
stuff very often so I'm I I never I'm
not quite sure how much there is to
explain but let me keep going so another
feature of neutron stars is they they
typically spin around very rapidly and
that's kind of for the same reason that
the that the Sun is spinning at a
certain speed if it were to be
compressed down to a neutron star it
would spin much faster in order to
conserve its so-called angular moments
angular momentum so okay so anyway this
neutron star it's spinning around very
rapidly it has electrons that are that
are producing radio waves and what
happens is as the as the thing spins
around it's essentially producing as it
because the the the way the electrons
got a little complicated in the
magnetosphere of a pulsar which is the
kind of the kind of sheath of magnetic
stuff around the Pulsar it's not quite
uniform and so they'll typically one
direction where it is producing more
radio energy radio waves than in other
directions and so the pulsar turns
around and as the Pulsar spins around
cheated here I already told you the
answer so this neutron star is I should
have said just neutron star is spinning
around it as it spins around it'll send
this beam of radio waves in in a
particular beam of radio waves that it's
producing will spin around as well and
so if we're over here and the earth as
this neutron star spins around every so
often its beam of its radio beam will
point towards the earth and so if we are
listening on the right radio frequency
we'll be able to essentially hear that
radio signal coming from the neutron
star okay so back in 1968 people were
doing radio astronomy they were trying
to use telescopes that kind of detect
radio waves and they discuss
this strange phenomenon that they were
hearing pulses in radio pulses that were
coming from particular stars in the sky
particularly the Crab Nebula is one one
famous one and so it's like what was
this I think I mentioned this last time
but but the you know you you hear this
kind of pulse and it's sort of regular
pulse and the first guess was gosh that
must be a beacon of some
extraterrestrial civilization that's
saying hello we're here you know it's
like a navigation beacon or something
from an extraterrestrial civilization
and that's what for the first two weeks
I think people thought that's what that
might be
and then they realize no actually it's a
neutron star and those things are called
pulsars pulsing stars and they pulsars
produce these sort of pulses of radio
energy I don't think that they produce I
don't think there's visible light that
gets generated if there is visible light
it comes from a different phenomenon of
accretion discs where there's matter
that's kind of being dragged into the
into the neutron star but I don't think
that happens with neutron stars it
happens with black holes I don't think
it happens with neutron stars but I
might be wrong about that
um but any case the the pulsars we now
know a whole bunch of pulsars around the
galaxy and they're there they're there
they're really cool objects because
though these they're these whole stars
that spin around like they're even
millisecond pulsars which means they
spin around a thousand times a second
the whole star is spinning a thousand
times a second and producing producing
radio signals that is about a thousand
times a second we hear a pulse from it
and you can do all kinds of weird things
like for example let's say you wanted to
work out how to do GPS in space so GPS
is you know how we find how cars and
planes and other things find their
position on the earth and the way it
works is there are satellites orbiting
the Earth the constellation of how many
it is these days maybe 6070 satellites
orbiting the Earth that each produce
pulses with a known interval and so when
you're
your GPS receiver can tell oh yes the
pulse I got from satellite number 17
took exactly 21 milliseconds
21.125 864 something or something
milliseconds to arrive because the
pulses are they have a certain code that
tells you when the pulse when the GPS
satellite produced that particular pulse
and you know when you measured that
pulse so that allows you to work out
because you know the speed of light you
can just work out um how far away the
satellite was and that tells you what
you're if you know three satellites you
can triangulate to find your position
okay so one of the questions is if we
were in space if we were doing some you
know we were going off and we were
sending up spacecraft to to Pluto or
something was far away from the GPS
satellites that are orbiting the earth
they're not gonna do us any good and
telling us we're app where our
spacecraft is how can we what's the kind
of inter interplanetary or even
interstellar version of GPS that we
could use and so one people one thing
people have thought about is to use
pulsars as kind of an interstellar GPS
system because we know where all these
pulsars are each pulsar has a definite
series of pulses that it produces and so
you can use that to figure out how far
exactly how far away are you from this
from all these different pulsars and
that gives you a way to get a kind of
location in interstellar space that
gives you sort of a way to do that I
mean a more simple-minded way to do it
which is what a lot of deep-space probes
do is to just have a little telescope
and they look for different stars and
they say when what what what is the
orientation of you know where what what
direction do I have to be pointed in to
see this star and that star and they do
things that way all right long answer to
that question all right we've got lots
and lots of other questions here um
let's see
come on improve mathematical and
scientific analytical thinking um bucks
to read and so on I'm not a huge expert
in what exists right now you know I
think you know the main thing I was like
to do is when I see stuff happen in the
world that I hear about stuff I just try
and learn how it works and you know the
web has lots of good sources of
information about sort of how things
work and you know try and read those
ones you don't understand try and figure
out you know what were the sort of
underlying concepts and try and get to
understand those I think that's a that's
a good place to go when you really want
to know sort of how things work learning
how to tell a computer what you want is
a is a really good way to do that I mean
I've spent a lot of my life building
this kind of computational language to
have us humans be able to explain to
computers what we want and I I always
find that the time when I really think I
understand something is when I can write
a little program that does the thing
that I'm talking about um that's kind of
my test for whether I actually
understand what I'm talking about and I
find that it's a really good way to kind
of organize one's thoughts to but kind
of explain it to a computer it's also
good explaining it to other people like
I'm trying to do right now um
I mean I'm gonna under script to some
more of the science questions here I can
talk maybe a different time about more
kind of computational thinking kinds of
things okay so the question from MC is
how the magnets work okay well there are
the all right magnets like lumps of
metal that make magnets I can explain
how those work you can also make magnets
by using electric fear by using
electricity and in the end magnets like
lumps of metal work in kind of the same
way as magnets that are made without
lectricity but it's a little bit tricky
to explain exactly their correspondence
so let me start off by talking about
magnets that are made a piece of metal
so the most common kinds of magnets bar
magnets made of iron the three chemical
elements iron cobalt nickel which are
next to each other in the periodic table
which means that they have adjacent
numbers of protons because the periodic
table just is this table of all the
different possible kinds of atoms where
each one is arranged from hydrogen
helium lithium beryllium etc each one is
hydrogen has one proton helium has two
protons etc that's that's how the
periodic table works in one part of the
table is iron cobalt nickel um and those
that's the most common thing that
magnets are made of they're also things
called rare earth magnets which are
actually much stronger magnets most
common let's see I think gadolinium
europium samarium I think a common
examples of rare earth magnets those are
those are also elements in the periodic
table they're also metals um and they
produce they allow you to make stronger
magnets okay so how these magnets work
well basically a big magnet like a big
lump of iron that's a magnet the way it
works is it has a lot of really tiny
magnets that are all lined up inside
those tiny magnets are actually iron
atoms and the iron atoms are themselves
little tiny magnets and the big thing
that makes the big lump of metal act
like a magnet is that all those little
tiny magnets are all lined up so here's
the thing not to do with a magnet that
you want don't put it in an oven and
because if you put it in an oven and
heat it up there's a temperature it's
called the Curie temperature at which it
loses its magnetic field it loses its
magnetism so what happens is just like
if you take a block of ice that's you
know solid all the atoms are all lined
up in the block of ice and you heat it
up eventually it'll turn into a liquid
and the atoms won't all be lined up
they'll all be you know running around
all over the place the same thing
happens in a magnet so an ordinary
magnet when it is magnetized and it is a
ordinary room temperature the the atoms
inside that magnet all have what are
called their spins that little tiny
magnet magnets are all lined up and so
that means you'll have trillions and
trillions of little tiny magnets all
lined up and they all line up in the
same direction and so they make a big
they make the whole thing act as a big
magnet if you heat it up it essentially
the magnets kind of it's it's like they
like they melt and it doesn't it's it's
long before the lump of iron actually
melts long before the the actual atoms
and the iron get separated to the point
where the iron becomes a liquid long
before that the the alignment of the
little tiny magnets that these iron
atoms are that gets broken down and so
your magnet will lose its magnetic field
so if you care about your magnet don't
heat it up to that point because it will
lose its magnetism now the good news is
you can always give it back its
magnetism if you if you put it in a
magnetic field again it will the the
iron atoms will line up again and you'll
make a magnet again although you might
make a magnet that's in a different
direction than the magnet that you had
before
so so the way that um the way that sort
of things like bar magnets big magnets
and things work is they have these
little tiny atomic scale magnets and
they all get lined up and that's how you
get one of these big magnets and it's
only certain metals that um certain
materials that have this feature that
their atoms can line up in this way um
it's still the case that if you picked
out an individual atom of almost any
element it could act like a tiny magnet
itself but it's only in certain
materials that all those little tiny
magnets can get lined up to make what's
called Ferro magnetism it's that's the
that's the name for the phenomenon where
where all the all the little tiny
magnets line up to make a big magnet so
anyway that's the way that magnets
that's the way things like bar magnets
work the the way that you can make a
magnetic field without having any of
these atomic magnets you do that by
having the electricity a magnetism are
closely related and it turns out that if
you have for example a loop of wire and
you have electricity flowing through
that loop of wire in it will produce a
magnetic field so maybe I could explain
another time how that really works but
basically when when electrons that make
electricity are moving around in a
circle they produce a magnetic field and
that is goes sort of sort of
perpendicular to the circle and that's
so that's how that's how electromagnets
electromagnets work and they're very
convenient like for example if you have
a you know a door that's supposed to be
locked or not locked you can do that by
having a what's called a solenoid which
is one of these electrode it's an
electromagnet and that means that when
if you have if there's an electric
current if there's electricity flowing
through this coil then it will produce
the magnet and if there isn't
electricity flowing through there it
won't make a magnet so if you have two
two of these things next to each other
for example you can say okay there's
electric
going through these so they make a
magnet so they're held together oh you
switch the electric field off open oh
break apart so that's a very convenient
thing because it means you can have
magnets that you can kind of switch on
and off just by switching electricity on
and off now the the tricky thing that's
a little bit more complicated is in some
sense the magnets that are these atomic
magnets are actually made from something
analogous to a loop of wire because
what's actually happening is that the
electrons in inside the atoms are kind
of going around the atoms just like the
electrons go around that loop of wire
but it's like a little tiny loop of wire
the size of an atom and that's kind of
how the magnetic field gets made in in
just at the level of the individual
atoms in iron for example now okay in in
sort of to be really exact there is
another thing that happens these
individual particles like an individual
electron actually is like a tiny bar
magnet and so I was telling you earlier
electrons are either of zero size or at
least very very small and so there's a
there's kind of a question of how how an
electron manages to have what it takes
to make a magnetic field just by just as
a thing itself and nobody knows how that
works it's I think this new theory that
I have for how fundamental physics works
probably explains that although I don't
yet know how that works I mean if you if
you're interested in there's a
phenomenon called spin which is a
feature of of particles again I'd be
happy to talk about it it's a it's a
it's an interesting and complicated
story electrons have spin 1/2 photons
have spin 1 all these different
particles have a certain spin which and
many of those particles when they have
an electric charge and they have a spin
they'll they will be act like little
magnets so ok long long answer to that
question all right
let's see why is their ultimate speed
limits of the speed of light well it's a
good question
the inn
well the ultimate answer is we don't
know it's a feature of our universe it's
a very important feature of our universe
um and we don't know why it works that
way now having said that in for example
my new theory of how physics works we
can understand well that's some yeah we
can understand a little bit more about
why there's a maximum speed so so the
speed of light
maximum speed that anything can go out
in our universe how big is the speed of
light the thing that's worth if you're
gonna remember one of these factoids
about light goes one foot in one
billionth of a second so in one
nanosecond
light goes one foot so that means in in
one second light goes a billion feet um
and it takes so for example to give us
some sense of scale it takes light eight
minutes to go from the Sun to the earth
it takes light what is it about a couple
of second notes gosh I have to work it
out um maybe a half a second or a second
to go to the moon so light goes fast but
not an infinite speed um and to go
across our whole universe takes a time
that's about the age of the universe
about fourteen billion years actually it
takes even longer than that to go all
the way across our universe but that
that's sort of a first approximation to
how how long it takes to go across the
universe but then so
what light the speed of light governs
the maximum rate at which we can send
signals so for example when you I don't
know like when we're using when we're
using the internet for example it's
often called the ping time on the
internet so one computer will ping
another computer there's a in low level
operating systems there's usually a
command called ping and you say ping and
then you say the name of a computer then
it will say up it took 200 milliseconds
two hundred thousandth of a second to
send a signal to that other computer and
get it back again okay so the the the
ping time is is this time for signal to
go from your computer to another
computer and get back and tell you how
long it took and so a question is is
that in fact is that time that's sort of
a that tells you how long it takes for
information to go from your computer to
another computer and in a first
approximation that is at least limit
well it's certainly limited by the speed
of light you'll never be able to get
your computer to ping another computer
faster than it would take light to go
from your computer to another computer
now how is the actual signal sent well
often a lot of signals now are in
fiber-optic cables so fiber optics is
like normally you know you shine a
flashlight or something and just shining
it through the air but you can also get
light to go through glass and you can
make these fiber optics where the light
goes into this fiber and it bounces off
the edges of the fiber and keeps
bouncing off the edges of the fiber and
the light will just keep going through
this fiber and so you can actually have
a single fiber that can be like probably
these days a hundred miles long and you
can just shine light in one end of that
fiber and the the glass is in the fiber
is sufficiently pure that the light will
just keep going keep going it'll bounce
off the walls but you won't lose any
light and you'll still be able to get
and you'll get the light out at the
other end and so a lot of the internet
is built with fiber optic cables where
the the speed of light where where it's
light that's transmitting the signals
that's telling you know that's going
from from my computer
camera two onto the the Internet and so
on and so on and so on now actually a
little bit of a footnote to that light
the speed of light that you hear about
you know one foot and a nanosecond and
so on
that's the speed of light in a vacuum
it's very close to the speed of light in
air the speed of light in air is a
little bit slower but the speed of light
in other materials is considerably
slower like in water it's 33% slower
than in a vacuum and in glass it's
typically about 50 percent slower well
it's the it's called the refractive
index which is the ratio of the speed of
light in a vacuum compared to the speed
of light in the material so for glass
that's between 1.5 and 1.7 usually um
and so that means that when when light
is going through glass it's not going at
its full speed of light speed
it's going at one-and-a-half times
slower than that speed why does that
happen
reason it happens is that in something
like glass the light is continually
getting absorbed by an atom re-emitted
by the atom so what happens is the light
hits an atom it makes the atom it puts
the atom in a new state where the atom
says I just absorbed a photon of light
and it takes the atom just a little bit
of time to remit that photon of light
and so it's like it's playing some kind
of relay type thing where the light is
falling on one atom takes the atom a
little bit of time to emit that light
again and keeps going and that's how
light gets transmitted through something
like glass um and that's why the light
is not going at the official speed of
light in glass anyway so the ping times
on the internet roughly roughly
determined by the speed of light in
glass now it's that's not the whole
story because what happens is the it's
not just going through this one cable it
also has to go through electronics that
tell it which cable to go through and
figure out how to switch things and so
on and actually a lot of the time the
lot of the time that's taken and
communicating between computers is
actually inside that switching stuff
rather than the actual trans
mission along the fibers but the actual
transmission along the fibers does take
some time and you can you can detect
that as you look at you know web sites
that are further away from you
physically and you'll find that it takes
longer to the ping times will tend to
get longer all right um was a question
here can you ask about the corona virus
only about sounds I can talk about grown
of iris what I know about it
um the okay
oh boy we're going to so somebody's got
to ask the question what is spin which I
let me avoid talking about that question
I'll I'm happy to talk about that
sometime but beome shall I try it
alright I'll try it okay um okay you
want me to you want me to tell you what
it actually is I'll tell you just
because fun to hear the words so the a
particle like an electron has a each
electron has a certain mass all
electrons have the same mass and the
well the official definition of spin it
is which irreducible representation of
the prank or a group does the electron
transform equipment I can use all the
fancy words I'm not going to use these
fancy words because this is absolutely
useless um let me try and explain so
those fancy words tell us that spin is
something that is sort of understood in
terms of mathematics and in terms of
fairly abstract concepts so I I have a
guess about what spin really is in terms
of the way that space is built and so on
I don't yet know if it's completely
correct but let me tell you kind of the
the standard realm we tell your mixture
of kind of what spin is so so roughly
you can have an object let's say I don't
know if you know like a top a top can be
spinning around right top spins around
and one of the things that happens with
the top is it just like ski likes to
keep on spinning just the way it's been
spinning and that's similar to if you
throw something it will tend to keep
going in the direction that you threw it
at least until gravity makes it turn
turn in a different direction that's so
the reason it does that one way to
explain that is it's conservation of
linear momentum there's this idea of
momentum when things when things are
moving it's some it's a mass and
velocity combined together make momentum
and so a massive object going in some
direction will tend to keep going in
that direction there's a in in physics
there's a conservation of momentum so
things starts going in that direction it
will keep going in that direction the
okay so that's linear momentum there's
also a conservation of angular momentum
when you start something spinning it
will tend to keep on spinning okay if
you have a top for example the top will
eventually stop spinning and the reason
for that is there's friction if the top
is just spinning on a little point
there's friction between that will tend
to slow down but friction for example
between the points and the table or
friction because the top is moving in
the air that will tend to slow the top
down but if there wasn't any friction if
you had this top spinning in space the
then then the thing would just keep
spinning around it would keep spinning
kind of forever
that's conservation of angular momentum
okay I have to tell you a story a friend
of mine who's a astronaut used to be an
astronaut had an experience with space
in space that was was a was a one of
these figure out physics and real-time
kinds of experiences so he was on the
space station called mer which was a
Russian space station was a pretty
Assessor of the current international
space station and he was on the space
station and the space station was some
there was some accident on the space
station and that caused the space
station to start rotating to start
spinning and in fact because there
wasn't any air to slow it down there was
nothing to slow it down the space
station just kept on spinning and so it
was a was a big question how should they
stop the space station spinning and in
fact my friend was used our Mathematica
program to to figure out in it you have
to be a very kind of cool cucumber of an
astronaut to be hanging out in a space
station that's spinning around and to
get out your computer and start writing
down differential equations and solve
the equations and things and figure out
yes if we fire this thruster in this
direction then we'll we'll stop the
space station spinning but he succeeded
in doing that and figured out figured
out just by using the math equations how
to stop that space station spinning and
then of course the the story be much
better if he'd been able to implement
what he what he figured out and that it
worked but in fact the Russian ground
controllers who were you know in charge
of what happens to their space station
were like no you can't do that that's
not our procedure we have a procedure
for what to do well we don't know
exactly what it is but anyway after
after a day or so they managed to use
some other procedure but it was kind of
a shame that the differential equations
for for solved in real time to stop the
spinning space station never actually
got able to be implemented but any case
so so in in large-scale objects there's
this idea of angular momentum and
there's a conservation of angular
momentum okay when you have a very small
object like an electron electrons also
spin around but when you have a big
object like a Space Station you
make it spin faster or you can make it
spin slower when you have an object like
an electron for reasons that we don't
yet fully understand you can effectively
only give it one particular amount of
angular momentum
so all electrons have in the units of
angular momentum that's used for
electrons they have half a unit in
angular momentum
so all electrons have half a unit of
angular momentum they can actually be
essentially they can be either plus half
a unit or minus half a unit that whole
story is a little bit complicated with
quantum mechanics but but roughly I
think it's fair to say an electron has
half a unit of angular momentum a proton
also has half a unit of angular momentum
photons have one unit of angular
momentum gravitons the particles that
make up gravity waves they have two
units of angular momentum and the number
of units of angular momentum that a
particle has has a big effect on how the
particle works and that the most
important effect is if you have an
integer number a whole number of units
of angular momentum your thing called a
boson if you have half a half integer
number of units Langan events Amir I
think all the fermion okay what's the
difference what's the big difference
between bosons and fermions basically
bosons are super social and like to
clump together and fermions are kind of
super anti-social and like to stay apart
okay why do we care well the reason we
care about fermions staying apart like
things like electrons and protons and so
on is that most matter that we deal with
atoms and things are made of fermions
and the fact that they like to stay
apart is what causes matter - not all
collapse so there's a thing called the
exclusion principle that basically says
when you have fermions things like
electrons things with half integer spin
they will never want to be sort of all
stuck together in this in the same place
they'll always want to be B be sort of
forced apart and that's what it's a
large part of what leads to the
stability of matter that leads to having
actual objects that don't sort of
collapse okay so that's what happens
with half and you just spin things with
with whole integer spin things I
mentioned that photons have spin one
photons are examples of bosons photons
are the particles of light they're
examples of bosons and bosons have the
property that if you have one boson it
really wants to have other bosons be
right there in the same state right on
top of it okay so you might say well so
what well the main so what of that is
that's how lasers work lasers the word
laser stands for light amplification by
stimulated emission of radiation and
what's happening there is that in a
laser you're trying to get lots of
photons to all be in exactly the same
state all being going in exactly the
same direction all shine out of the
front of the laser so to speak and it's
because photons are bosons that it's
possible to these electrons really like
kind of clumping together and all being
in the same state and all making this
coherent laser light that you produce in
a laser so they're these two so the spin
is this property of particles that has
to do with angular momentum and it
really matters whether things have half
a unit of spin or one unit of spin and
that um that's a very well if you study
theoretical physics in graduate school
you might hear about a thing called the
spin statistics theorem which is a which
is the which is the piece of mathematics
that shows that there's a connection
between the spin of a particle and
whether it wants to be clumped together
or a stayer part I could mention one
more thing about that which might be too
complicated but well okay just a a thing
if you're curious can look up there
things called spinners and normally when
we have something in ordinary
three-dimensional space and we rotate it
around we rotate 180 degrees it's
backwards
we rotate it 360 degrees it comes back
to where it started from again
okay um turns out for things like
electrons they don't work that way they
actually
you turn them around by by 360 degrees
they don't come back to where they
started from you need to turn them
around by 720 degrees you need to turn
them around essentially two full
revolutions before they come back to
where they started from again and that's
a weird and interesting phenomenon that
I could talk about some other time okay
let's see
okay so question here boy you guys are
asking about physics a lot
ah let me see
um gosh lots of great questions here um
what should I try and
a bunch about physics let me let me try
and talk a little bit about math um
since there's a question here about math
it's a question about statistics let me
see all right let's talk about
statistics well I think for that I have
to get my and actually do something with
a computer let me do that hold on a
second here okay all right
let's see what we can do with statistics
I'm kind of looking at my screen here so
I might be looking up in a rather
strange angle that sorry about that um
okay well where should we start I think
a good place to start is talking about
averages so if we say let's say we make
I'm gonna make a bunch of I'm gonna make
50 numbers between let's make them
between 1 and 10 I mean I 50 random
numbers between 1 and 10 so one question
you might ask is what's the average of
those numbers so let's say for example
those are I don't know distances you
throw a ball or something like that you
could say what's the average of those
numbers and so they're they're various
ways to work out that average maybe
actually let me let me do something
slightly different here let me make my
room numbers a slightly different way um
let me say this oops
I wanted sorry okay so here I've got a
bunch of numbers and I want to say
what's the average of these numbers okay
so one convenient thing to try to do is
to make histogram so a histogram let me
just make it here so a histogram says
let's put these numbers in in buckets
let's say how many numbers are there
between zero and two how many numbers
are there between two and four how many
numbers are there between four and six
so this is saying for each bucket like
this is the numbers between zero and two
this is saying that I can't read this
off here but there but maybe 16 numbers
between zero and two same 16 numbers
between two and four some I don't know
how many it is six numbers between 4 and
6 and so on okay so we have numbers in
these various buckets and so this
histogram we can say if we want to say
given these numbers what's the chance if
we were to pick it okay let's imagine
that we we wanted to say what's what's
the chance that one of these numbers is
between let's say zero and four what
we'd have to say is what how much stuff
is there that falls between in these
buckets between zero and four compared
to all the other stuff and that will
give us the so so let's imagine I mean
let me give a slightly different example
but let me let me keep going on this let
me let me show you let's say let me do a
few more of these let's say we do 500 of
those and let me make the same histogram
again so I'm just I'm just using um so
now I'm going to ask the question let's
imagine that this is the this is heights
of different what can what's about that
height I don't know pet grasshoppers
that are different no I don't think
there are negative height pet
grasshoppers bad idea uh what could this
be
this could be
[Music]
distance snail walks towards a piece of
lettuce in a few minutes and sometimes
the snail walks backwards so it's a
negative number okay but anyway so now
we want to ask something like what's the
average distance that the snail walks
towards the lettuce and so how do we
work that out from this well what what
do we think the average is what we might
say what's the if we if we were to cut
this out as a piece of paper and we
would try to balance it would say where
where would we put the balance that
would make it be sort of an equal amount
of paper to the right and to the left so
that's one one way that we could sort of
decide what's what's the middle of this
what's the what's the what do we count
as the average of this of this set of
distances the snail might go and that
that way of working things out is called
the mean of the distribution another
thing we might do is we might say I want
to I want to say let's make sure that
half of the and this mainly not the best
way to explain it I think I should have
them so there are these different kinds
of averages
there's mean median mode so the mode is
an easy one to explain the mode is
what's the most likely what's the most
likely value so that would be this
bucket here so they're these different
different kinds of kinds of averages but
but in general this sum so like this
might be a distribution that it's the
same shape distribution there's a very
common shape of distribution it's called
a normal distribution or Gaussian
distribution or bell curve sometimes and
a lot of things follow that distribution
so for example for human Heights they
follow that distribution for any given
age etc you'll if you work out what's
the distribution of heights and I'm sure
I can do this if I if I pull up with
malphur let me um let me do that yeah
a
[Music]
go let's um let's say let's say I don't
know girl
age 12 height so and you can do this
with Syria and things like that which
are powered by wolf knife ride pretty
sure they they give you this information
now that's not good let's let's ask it
let's say um oh I see
okay there we go so this tells us for
girls age 12
this tells us if we looked at lots and
lots of lots and lots of kids this shows
us the distribution of their heights so
it tells us the most probable height
seems to be well it's a little bit under
5 feet here and this tells us the the
the this tells us what the distribution
of heights is so if you were to have a
bunch of kids and and you were to
measure all their Heights and you were
to put them in in bins of you know who
is between this number of inches and
that number of inches the number of kids
would correspond to the different bins
here so that's the that's the
distribution of human Heights so for
example you might say let's say you are
you know 4 foot of 5 inches tall you
might say oh boy that makes me really
weird I must be you know there must be
so few people who are my height ok this
curve tells you how many people are less
tall than you are and more tall than you
are
all you have to do is work out the area
under this curve so the number of people
who are less tall than you are if you're
4 foot 5 inches tall the number of
people less tall than you are is the
number of people in this in this tale
here and the number of people taller
than you is the total number is the
total area above you and so when so for
example this actually says the 95
percent range corresponds to four foot
five to five feet five four foot five
point six inches so what that's saying
is 95 percent of people
95 percent of girls age 12 are between
four foot five point six inches and five
foot five point three inches tall okay
and you can read that off from this
distribution that's telling you the area
ninety-five percent of the area 95% of
the if you pick a pick a kid at random
then 95 percent of the time they will be
between the site and the site and about
five percent of the time they'll either
be shorter than that or taller than that
okay so you might you might ask I mean
not all not all things are distributed
like this so for example I know oh yeah
we have a plot here the weight
distribution human weights have a
different distribution they actually
have a thing that's called the log
normal distribution roughly so that
means that there are there's a there's a
tail here where there are people who are
larger and heavier and there are more of
those than there are people who are
lighter and so it's a slightly different
set up and if you look at different
kinds of things these distributions you
get different kinds of distributions so
for example if we look at oh I don't
know if we look in the stock market at
the prices of stocks their prices
bounced around owner let's pick a
company let's see um how about Apple see
what's been happening with them um so
that's their poor Apple um
that's their stock price and this is
showing the distribution this is showing
what they're the middle is their average
stock price and this is showing how
their stock price differs what what the
chance is that you will find us a price
if you look at different days or
different hours of the day that is 10%
higher 19% lower and so on and so this
some it's again that this distribution
is roughly for stocks very roughly also
a normal distribution
although stocks tend to have tails and
there all sorts of terrible things that
happen so for example the the
distribution might say what gosh you can
go down to have there's a certain
probability to have a negative stock
price but actually there can't be a
negative stock price the company
wouldn't be in business if there was a
negative stock price so that means it
can't be exactly that distribution but
so that's a that's a little bit of a
micro introduction to a little bit of
statistical stuff so one thing that
happens like when people talk about
medical tests and they say things like
they talk about p-values and they talk
about you know this test works X percent
of the time and so on or this the value
of this thing is such and such with a
90% confidence interval a 95% confidence
interval just means that the
distribution 95% of the time the values
will lie between the VAT what what is if
you say this this the value of this
thing is between -2 and 4 with 95%
confidence interval it's saying that 95%
of the area of the statistical
distribution lies between minus 2 and 4
now unfortunately because I think I
might say because people who are you
know racing to do frontline medicine and
so on don't always know or learn as much
math as they might sometimes that gets a
little bit messed up and people end up
quoting these kinds of things like these
things called p-values they quote them
and they say it's this value to this
value based on some experimental data
and they assume that it follows one of
these normal distributions and actually
it just doesn't um and so that that
leads to some some things that are kind
of hard to figure out and it's it's
usually better to look at the actual
distribution so for example if we look
at some what's a good example let's see
what would be an example of well for the
for the old folk um let's see
say okay this is this is more for the
for the parent crowd if you if you
measure that's as cholesterol measure
cholesterol in a male age 40 again you
get one of these distributions this is
telling you what the chances are this
says the most likely um okay so this is
saying ninety-five percent of males age
forty if you measure that LDL
cholesterol level it will lie between 65
and two hundred so and this one Sigma
means 68 percent lie between 92 and
hundred and sixty one of these units so
there's another one of these
distributions and a lot of the time
people will quote oh you have a normal
cholesterol level okay what does that
actually mean
well it often means that you lie within
the 95% confidence interval sometimes it
means you lie within the 68% the one
Sigma confidence level and so on anyway
that was a really micro introduction to
some things and statistics side there's
statistics is a big subject and I'm
really not doing it justice here but
that was just a little sort of micro
micro discussion there all right let me
go back to our stream here if I can work
this properly let's see um all right
okay so there's a question here about
did humans evolved from monkeys okay so
the first statement to make is there's
this whole phenomenon of of evolution
there's this whole tree of life that's
existed on earth and maybe it started I
don't know two and a half billion years
ago maybe that the first living
organisms existed and ever since then
we've been and the even from the very
beginning probably well probably not the
very very first living organisms but
fairly soon DNA this molecule that is
essentially gives us the program that
specifies how to build an organism
pretty soon organisms started using DNA
to specify the program that would be
used to build them and like you know our
DNA has six billion base pairs
essentially six billion well six billion
times two bits of information that
specify how to build us and they specify
how our cells should make should turn
our food into proteins and and make make
everything that's us okay so back in the
you know when when when life first of
all done Earth probably it didn't
actually use DNA probably it used I
don't know there's some theories that it
used things in clay and clays and other
other kinds of ways to sort of keep
information about how it should be built
but roughly what's happened is that over
the course of time the program for
building life for building organisms has
gradually been refined and refined and
refined and refined and refined and
every time there's a new generation of
organisms their programs are a little
bit different than their parents
programs and what happens there's this
phenomenon called natural selection that
was discovered in the about century and
a half ago now and that by Charles
Darwin um and with various input from
other people but but um again don't get
me started I'm talking about history of
science I can give you a
long long discussion about that but
let's state it stick to the point so
what is natural selection so there are
each organism is specified by a program
the children of the organism get
programs that differ just a little bit
from the the programs of their parents
in the case of us humans and organisms
that have sexual reproduction we always
get a mixture of the programs from our
mother and our Father and so like with
humans we have 23 chromosomes and the
each and each one of those
there'll be stretches that are your
father's DNA your mother's DNA and so on
they're usually about I think it's five
or six crossovers per chromosome so
you'll get you know if you have siblings
for example you'll be able to see oh
that section of chromosome five
we both got that from our father for
example um and then it will cross over
and you'll get it from the other parents
and so on and because the program on the
DNA is so jumbled up it's not the case
it's not a well-organized program so to
speak so you're like the the piece of
the program that might encode how you
know I color how one part of our eye
color works maybe on a completely
different chromosome from the part that
encodes on another part of our eye color
works and so it's not the case that just
because you know you have sort of
sections of DNA that come from one
parent or another it doesn't mean that
the traits are necessarily very
correlated but any case the so different
organisms gradually as as you you
compared to your parents have slightly
different DNA one reason for that is
because of this phenomenon of the mixing
of DNA from from sexual reproduction
another feature is that when DNA is is
replicated there are some errors in
replication and those errors some of
those errors are corrected by
proofreading enzymes and things but some
are not and so each of us probably has
about 700 thousand unique base pairs
unique places on our DNA that nobody
else got that
just completely unique to us okay so
then what happens well over the course
of time some of those unique mutations
some of those mutations will turn out to
be a really good idea so for example I
don't know let's pick gosh let's not go
for humans let's go for let's go for the
classic thing that Darwin studied which
was a type of bird that had different
shapes of beak um and so and he looked
at birds and the Galapagos Islands and
the different islands there and on some
islands the there was what was it some
kinds of seeds I guess that existed
where if you had a particular shape of
beak you'd be more successful at
cracking open that seed I may have that
slightly wrong what the actual different
functionalities of these birds is but
it's roughly that and that certainly one
one can imagine um so you know if you
have a beak of a certain shape it's
gonna be really good for cracking up in
that seed okay if you have that shape of
beak you'll be a more successful bird
you will live longer you will have more
children and so what then happens is
that the this process of natural
selection of selecting out birds that
aren't so successful and selecting in
birds that are successful as that
continues through generations you'll
tend to get evolution towards for
example a bird that has a beak that's
really optimized what it's trying to do
now natural selection and evolution can
be good and it can be kind of bad and so
for example one case where it's bad is
in things like viruses they they have
natural selection and evolution as well
well let me give you the example of
bacteria so one bad example there is
antibiotic resistant bacteria so
bacteria are you know we have
antibiotics antibiotics kill bacteria
but so if you're an out if you're a
bacterium and you're reproducing and
you're in a place where they're a bunch
of antibiotics and antibiotics kill you
then you won't reproduce but if you
sudden blood by some mutation manage to
be a bacterium that survives the
antibiotics then you'll be the winning
bacterium and you'll reproduce and
they'll be lost
copies of you and so that's that's the
thing that happens is that the the the
the antibiotic will provide sort of work
force that will select for bacteria that
aren't killed by the antibiotic and so
you'll evolve bacteria that are
antibiotic resistant in that case okay
so in the history of life on Earth we
have evolved all kinds of different life
forms that are successful in different
places so for example there's there's
life that lives in volcanoes there's
life that lives we actually don't know
how far down life lives inside the earth
but there's life that lives deep deeper
inside the earth we don't know quite how
deep there's life that lives in very
cold places very hot places places with
this feature that feature and those
different forms of life the ones that
survive and that are naturally selected
for are the ones that because of
mutations ended up being successful in
those particular environments well back
in the time of Charles Darwin he
actually thought that it was a sort of
feature of natural selection that it
would force one to have more and more
complex organisms organisms as more and
more elaborate features over the course
of time that turns out not to be true it
is not the case that more elaborate
organisms are always more successful
organisms I mean in the situation we're
in right now it'd be really good if that
was definitively true because we're
we're significantly more complex
organisms than this nasty virus that's
attacking us
you know for example we have it's not a
great measure of this but we have six
billion base pairs for a human the virus
has twenty-nine thousand base pairs very
tiny compared to us but the it so it so
Darwin thought that that gradually life
would get more and more complex and that
the more successful forms of life will
be more complex that doesn't seem to be
the case you can have quite successful
life forms that are quite simple but so
so then one of the questions is so
another another question sort of what
evolves from what and you know we the
best
life-forms that have ever evolved and
how does that how do you measure that
and how do you think about that um the I
think the specific question were here
was do we evolved from monkeys the okay
so first question is how would you tell
so the way that people used to tell what
evolved from what is to just look at the
organisms and say gosh that you know
humans look quite a lot like monkeys
you know zebras look quite a lot like
horses you know etc etc etc and they
tried to arrange the tree of life just
based on what organisms look like and
they're about roughly 10 million species
that are now and now a large fraction of
which are things like beetles that exist
in the Amazon rainforest things like
that but anyway they're there many
they're quite few mammalian species now
and I think ooh
how many are there maybe 10,000 maybe
less than that mammalian species that
are known the quite quite small number
but in any case of all these different
species that are known well we have so
you can try and group them together you
can transfer reconstruct this tree of
life of what evolved from what by just
looking at what looks similar to what
and so you know one of the things that
has been observed as they're fossils
which show what what organisms that have
existed in the past looked like and so
we can try and piece together what was
the kind of historical tree of life by
piecing together
well this fossil looks like this one and
looks like this one we can try make a
chain going all the way back and
sometimes you know a lot of fossils we
can make those kinds of chains there are
some wonderful fossils like from the
Cambrian period let's see a couple to
three hundred million years ago I think
that there are fossils from from well
actually the Precambrian period where
they're really weird-looking organisms
that don't look anything like the
organisms we have today there were kind
of things that in a sense evolution
tried out and they turned out not to be
very good ideas or at least for whatever
historical accidental reason they didn't
make it so for example just like we have
five fingers and a lot of organisms that
have fivefold symmetry there were
organisms at that time that have you
know seven folds
symmetry and all kinds of other things
and for whatever reason the the five
folders one out okay
so so one way that we can tell kind of
what evolved from what is just look at
the shapes of the organisms and try and
sort of piece it together
another thing that's become possible
more recently is to look at the DNA
sequences the programs for these
organisms at least the ones that exist
today sometimes we can get some some DNA
from from ancient organisms the sort of
a hope we might get term you know
there's good science fiction from
getting dinosaur DNA and things like
this that hasn't been successfully got
yet but um but it might be possible but
we can also just time the deuce from if
if we know the DNA of this organism
looked like this and we know it's a
small change from the program of one
organism to the program of the organism
that was the results of a bunch of
mutations from that organism we can kind
of try and piece together this tree of
life also by looking at the level of
programs so people have tried to do that
for humans I'm not a huge expert on all
the things that have been found but it's
clear that there were a bunch of species
that existed couple of million years ago
I think modern humans are maybe fifty
thousand years old or something um but
there were a bunch of species that
existed and they had different
characteristics some of them probably
only went extinct I think there's one
Homo florensis that I think may have
existed until five hundred years ago
there's a very kind of hobbit-sized
human-like organism that and and there
were also in the and earth all the and
earth ours which were different species
the Denisovans which were another
species I think there's actually very
recently the last couple of months
there's a there's a discovery in Africa
of probably a signs of yet another
species and all these different species
were pretty similar and they they they
interbred and in fact for example for us
like we have signatures of the
Neanderthal species for example in us I
think um blue eyes for example I think
of one of the contribution
Neanderthals to to modern humans and so
on so we can kind of try and piece
together what came from different
species and how that worked um but so
that's uh and it's it's always a
question of when when there were a
particular sort of innovations that were
made in history like you know what
species first had language what species
first made art and though there's a
that's a thing that's actually pretty
actively discussed these days you know
did the Neanderthals make art did they
have what kind of language did they have
it's it's often hard to tell you know
you can look at the vocal tracts and
things like that the structures inside
the kind of the floats and things of in
skeletons of these of these organisms
and you can try and guess do they have
that they have the kind of thing it
would take to have you know to make
different different sounds and so on I'm
not sure that's a totally convincing way
to do it if you're lucky you'll find a
cave painting or something or an
artifact it's it's even that's a hard
business to because the artifacts that
we find like like flint knapping one of
those things that I suppose got taught
in school back you know ten thousand
years ago but it's kind of been lost
since then it's like how do you take a
flint piece of piece of rock you just
keep knock-knock-knock on the flint and
eventually you can make it sharp and
that's a good thing if we're trying to
make an arrowhead and so back in the day
you know in ancient history of our
species you know that was a that was a
super useful skill is how to make um you
know how to make sharp points out of
Flint's um and uh but you know if you
find a an arrowhead that was made with
flint knapping it's pretty hard to tell
that you know it's a it's a we okay we
know how flint knapping works because
kind of flint knapping sort of survived
until modern times but if we found some
rock that was you know seem to be
chipped away in some weird shape to know
that that was something that was done
purposefully by some distant ancestor of
ours is a tough thing it's a tough thing
to know you know did they like like we
know from archaeology and things like
that um we know
what um when we look at sort of ancient
monuments we say what was this for and
it's often hard to tell all right let's
see um the AH gosh look at some of these
[Music]
whoo this is one I don't know the answer
to I'm sorry I'll tell you the question
but I don't know the answer it says why
does an egg turn into rubber when put in
vinegar well I know it doesn't actually
turn into rubber um but it may turn into
a rubbery substance I'm gonna I can
guess the answer I the you know an egg
has protein in it and proteins are very
long long molecules and what and the
kind of the consistency of these long
molecules and that's how rubber works
actually is is affected by by how how
much how far these molecules are kept
apart but I'm I'm sort of guessing here
um and so let me let me not Tim I'm
sorry I don't know the answer to that um
all right there's a question here is
there a maximum temperature okay that
one I can answer um okay so let's talk
about what temperature is I actually
talked about that in the last one of
these a little bit so when you have a
bunch of atoms temperature is basically
the energy with which those atoms are
bouncing around roughly the speed would
routes to the atoms are bouncing around
so in air we take let's take water in
steam the atoms are running around
really pretty fast it's a gas you cool
it down the atoms are running around a
bit slower and they're kind of being
stuck together a bit and that makes
liquid water if you cool the atoms down
even further they'll tend to just be
they'll tend to not run around very much
at all and they'll be kind of locked in
place and that makes solid ice
okay so temperature is it's actually the
the the average kinetic energy the
average energy of motion of motion of
the atoms or molecules in a substance
and or whatever is making up the
substance um
so that's so temperature is associated
with these microscopic motions in in a
material and the the so that means
there's a there's a an absolute zero or
a minimum temperature because there's a
temperature at which you've taken all of
that energy of motion out and the atoms
are just staying completely still and so
I think I mentioned last time the so
that means most materials turn into
solids when you take them down to
absolute zero of temperature absolute
zero is minus 273 point one six degrees
centigrade so it gets very cold and for
example you know as you so for example
when you cool air down air there's
mostly nitrogen and oxygen becomes our
minus 170 degrees centigrade is that
right I have to look that up I think
that's the temperature at which air
becomes liquid um and um I see so many
seven kelvins I think so right
no I'm forgetting sorry um I have to
look that up
I can type it into an alpha and look
that up um
but okay so there's a temperature at
which air becomes liquid there's a
temperature below that at which air
becomes solid those those temperatures
correspond to the molecules getting
slower and slower and slower okay all
right is there a maximum temperature
okay so well when you heat stuff up the
what's going to happen the molecules are
going to go faster and faster and faster
boy this is actually tricky this is this
is graduate level physics sorry I it's
some okay so what time you put more and
more energy into these into these atoms
well first of all as you put too much
energy and the atoms will fall apart and
it'll just be because when you the atoms
are held together by a certain amount of
force and when you when you try and when
you put in too much temperature
the atoms are sort of torn apart so what
happens in fire and things like that it
makes a plasma where the atoms are the
electrons are torn out of the atoms okay
but when you make things hot enough
everything gets torn apart even atomic
nuclei get torn apart when you make
things even hotter even the the quarks
and gluons inside protons and things get
sort of torn apart um but so when
everything is really really hot things
get torn apart but these particles
electrons whatever they are quarks
whatever they can just keep going and
you can just pump more and more and more
energy into those particles so actually
in the usual theory of physics there is
not a maximum temperature you can just
keep on pumping more and more and more
energy into inter particles there used
to be a theory that there was a maximum
temperature and that came about ah let's
see how to explain this okay
basically the idea was we know about
protons and neutrons and electrons but
they're actually a whole zoo of other
kinds of particles most of those
particles are unstable they decay and
millionths of a second or trillionth of
a second or trillion trillionth of a
second most in they're unstable but
there's a whole giant zoo of other
particles they have names like the Sigma
hyper on the lambda hyper on the cascade
hyper on the K on the PI on the F mez on
the G Mazon as a whole giant zoo of
these things but when I was a kid I was
really into these kinds of particles and
I used to know all about these things I
am it was some I have a decent memory so
I still remember you know the masses and
properties of a bunch of these particles
it's a little bit um they'd been
measured vastly more accurately than
they were known when I was a kid um but
in case there's a whole zoo of these
particles okay and it used to be thought
that maybe as you increase the
temperature of something instead of the
temperature instead of the energy going
into producing producing making
particles go faster instead that energy
would go into producing more kinds of
particles
and actually if you've heard of string
theory it's one of the kind of
mathematical theories that's thought
about a bit in fundamental physics
string theory the original version of
string theory came out of a theory of
particles in which there were just a
whole zoo of more and more and more and
more particles so it used to be thought
at one time that there was a maximum
possible temperature at which you would
be producing new kinds of particles
rather than the same kinds of particles
going faster that theory turns out not
to be correct it's an interesting
question whether in my theory of physics
whether there is ultimately a maximum
temperature umm Baba what is the answer
to that the answer is that there will be
um let's see yes actually I okay let me
answer to two different related
questions here so one place where things
got really hot was in the very early
universe when the universe was was just
started there was this Big Bang nobody
knows why that happened but was a sort
of giant explosion that started the
universe and when the universe was very
small and very young it was also very
hot and as time has gone on the universe
is cooled down it's cooled down it's
cooled down at this point be sort of if
you just go into space space is not at
an absolute zero of temperature space is
at about three degrees Kelvin three
kelvins which is minus 270 degrees
centigrade three degrees above absolute
zero that's that that's the effective
temperature of space and the reason it's
not at Absolute Zero is that it still
has sort of the the remnants of the heat
that came from the Big Bang in the at
the beginning of the universe is still
is still there in the in the in
essentially the the well photons the
microwave the the radio energy in the
universe that still sort of a relic of
of the Big Bang although by now because
the universe has expanded a lot it's
really cooled down so it's only three
degrees above absolute zero but in the
in the very early universe the universe
was really really really hot in fact
probably in some sense infinitely hot
now you're going to ask me to do some
kind of advanced physics in real time of
physic
theory that is is not yet fully
developed but I think in my theory of
fundamental physics there isn't and
there is a maximum temperature and I
think that that maximum temperature let
me think about this for a second
yes yes there will be a maximum
temperature and it will be let's see the
reason there's a maximum temperature I
mean the maximum temperature will be
unbelievably huge compared to anything
that we can observe in the universe with
the possible exception that at the edge
of a black hole one might see some
phenomenon associated with that I have
to think about that that is a good
question thank you that that's my
homework I think is to figure out in my
theory of how space-time works how
maximum temperature works so I somebody
somebody who's paying attention to live
stream from my team take a note of that
that's my that's my homework
um let's see let's see um okay here's
another question is there a maximum
location accuracy for a GPS system um
the
okay okay first of all let me four
people
let me explain again a little bit about
how GPS works GPS the global positioning
system that's a American network of
satellites and there's actually a
European one and there's a Russian one I
think that but the the GPS is the is the
most commonly used one okay so one big
question is how do you know where you
are on the earth that was a big issue
when people were you know particularly
on the oceans you know if you're trying
to figure out where am I and I'm you
know near where I near my house or
something it's like oh I know that
that's you know I recognize that
landmark but on the ocean there aren't
any landmarks to recognize so it's much
harder to tell where you are and so what
time so the main way that people used to
tell where they were is by navigating by
the Stars and the reason that that will
tell you where you are is the stars as
the Earth rotates the the stars will be
at particular the Stars stay at a fixed
location and as the Earth turns you can
you can basically see where the stars
are now it turns out that if you are to
know your latitude that is how far you
are from the north pole or from the
equator the how far north you are
basically that's something you can
figure out just from angles of stars as
the Earth turns you know where the north
star is which is roughly aligned with
the North Pole and you can you can
figure out by seeing what angle the
north north the Polaris the the north
pole star is at or a corresponding thing
in the southern hemisphere you can
figure out what latitude you're at it
was a big problem for many years to
figure out the longitude because to work
out longitude you have to know what time
it is you have to know to know you know
this star is overhead okay great but
what time does that correspond to and so
is a big issue of hiking and accurate
enough clock
to be able to know what time it is and
so there was this big thing to find to
create a marine chronometer and the big
issue is clocks used to be well they
were made with pendulums which swung
back and forth well they're made with
them with escapement I guess these these
sort of Springs that that um but
essentially it's little pendulum type
things and the problem is if you're in a
ship and it's on an ocean and you're
being thrown around all over the place
it's really hard to get the clock to
keep accurate time and so people
invented these whole elaborate systems
to kind of keep the clock from being
bounced around too much in the ocean and
keep it keeping accurate time and
eventually that problem was solved but
that was a that was sort of so that was
you know the earlier nerely system for
navigation ok so then when when
airplanes started flying it was there
was a need for navigation for planes for
planes as a different scheme that was
used for planes there are radio
navigation beacons in the US they
usually called vortex VHF
omnidirectional radio beacons and the
way they work they're kind of clever
actually you can see them sometimes
they're there you can see them they're
often near airports sometimes they're
sort of on hillsides and things they're
kind of these things that have a they
usually have from kind of this kind of
shape um they they're radio beacons and
they produce a so if you are flying a
plane
you back in the before there was GPS you
would try and get a fix on a radio
beacon and you would say this radio
beacon is at this angle to me and
actually these radio beacons have a
clever feature that they actually had
two different radio frequencies and as
you go around a circle around that radio
beacon the relative these two relative
frequencies would change as you go
around the circle just by the
construction of the radio antenna in the
radio beacon and so that allowed you to
tell what angle were you at relative to
that radio beacon and that was a that
was a method of navigation that was used
in fact still the airplanes
might think airplanes can go anywhere in
the sky but actually they tend to follow
these these particular sort of Airways
which typically are flying from one
radio beacon to the next radio beacon in
straight lines if that eventually is
going to get figured out how to let
planes use GPS and take arbitrary paths
and that will save some fuel and other
good things but Tim but any case so that
was a another scheme and then GPS was
invented and GPS is a different idea GPS
is using satellites and okay so how does
GPS work basically the the satellites so
first fact is once you put a satellite
in orbit you can compute just with math
really pretty accurately where that
satellite will be at every moment and so
you know if you type into off now for
the name of some satellite or the
International Space Station or something
it will predict for you where the
International Space Station is going to
be three days from now and it can do
that quite accurately because the the
physics of orbits and things is such
that you just work out these equations
differential equations and they tell you
sometimes of kind of complicated but
they tell you just by math where the
thing will be now the math all breaks
down if you have if your think fires a
little rocket thruster then you can make
it change its orbit but assuming it
fired no thrusters you can assume it
fired no thrusters assuming it didn't
hit the upper atmosphere hit the top of
the atmosphere and start getting slowed
down by that assuming no those weird
things happened you can just by physics
and math you can predict where the thing
will be to pretty really very high
accuracy okay so that there are these
GPS satellites and they're orbiting the
Earth and they you can predict where any
one of those satellites will be okay so
then if you want to know where you are
you have to say well how far away am i
from those satellites so if you want to
work out if you say where am i if I'm
somewhere on a line and I know I'm this
distance from one end of the line then I
know where I
on that line and if I if I want to work
out in in if I if I knew in
two-dimensions if I if I knew I was
somewhere on on a flat plane and I know
I'm this distance from one I know in
this distance for let's say I know I'm
ten miles away well that's be more
realistic let's say I'm a thousand miles
away from this point on the plane well
what points are a thousand miles away
from this point the answer is it's a
circle the the set of points that are a
thousand miles away or is is a circle
with a radius of a thousand miles around
that point okay so let's say I now know
I'm a thousand miles away from that
point and I'm 800 miles away from this
other point over here okay so where am i
if I know that I'm a thousand miles away
from this I know I'm somewhere on the
circle around that point I'm eight
hundred miles away from this I know I'm
somewhere on the circle eight hundred
was radius eight hundred miles around
that point okay so I've got these two
circles and that means that with with
these two circles if I want to know if I
know I'm a thousand miles away from this
one
801 I can work out where I can be the
answer is I must be on the circle around
this point and the circle around this
point and so my I must be on the
intersection of those two circles so if
you have two circles generically they
will intersect in two points okay so
just from two from knowing how far away
you are from two things you can work out
at least with between two points you can
say where am I relative to those circles
well if you want to break the ambiguity
of those two points you need a third fix
you know third you know the distance to
a third point and given those three
points you can work out where am i
exactly so that's kind of the idea that
GPS uses it tries to work out how far
away are you from three satellites
usually it's five satellites or more
that actually get used in a typical GPS
receiver and the somebody's asking how
far away am i from the GPS satellites
all right let me let me let me ask off
alpha here class of satellites it'll
give me the if we type this in here I'll
just show you
[Music]
hold on we just bring this up okay
yes and so of malphur this is showing me
apparently there are 39 GPS satellites
and the okay so this is telling me the
all kinds of details of GPS satellites
so it's telling me that the transmission
delay from me to the GPS satellites 186
milliseconds round-trip to that GPS
satellite so if I pick one of these GPS
satellites I'm sure I can get a picture
somewhere here of where all the GPS
satellites are but um let's let's pick
Navstar - eh - twelve let's see whether
it knows where that satellite is oh it's
probably computing it busily here okay
that satellite is currently over the
southern ocean southern Indian Ocean
it is thirty thousand miles altitude the
transmission delay is 224 milliseconds
the satellite is going that term that's
actually interesting instantaneous oh
that's because it's not in low-earth
orbit okay this confused me because a
satellite in low Earth orbit is always
going at 17,000 miles an hour but this
is not so low to the earth yeah it says
it's medium Earth orbit okay so this is
telling me that satellite was launched
1993 okay so it's telling me the
distance to that satellite okay you
really want me to work it out I can work
out the actual distance to that
satellite um but this is telling me the
round-trip time to the satellite from
where I am right now but I could work
out and see what is this called now star
2a - 12 all right let's try typing that
in Navstar
2a - 12 see if this works
he's looking very dangerously here okay
let's try typing under whether we have a
let me just work out what says I need to
know I'm actually probably if I just say
where is it where is it where is it I
want the out the position um where is it
position there we go
okay all right this is really living
dangerously but let's do it okay so this
is going to tell me the position of that
satellite okay so that tells me right
now that satellite is at latitude - 38
degrees that means it's in the southern
hemisphere longitude 81 degrees that
means it's somewhere over on the east so
to speak and this is the altitude and
meters of that satellite okay so let's
say where am i I'm in Concord
Massachusetts so let's at least get um
I'm not going to give you my precise GPS
coordinate but let's just use the center
of Concord Massachusetts so let's say
the Geo position of the center of
Concord Massachusetts and that's going
to give that now I can work out at least
on the surface of the earth it's easy
for me to work out the Geo distance from
that Geo position to the Geo position
that the satellite was at when I asked
the question because the satellite
remember is moving at 8,500 miles an
hour so it's actually going to be in a
different position by now okay so the
satellite is is some about ten thousand
miles from where I am right now
and we could work out um I think that
might not be the slant position if I
want to get that I can say that I am at
I think that gives us let me see that
gives us see this is where things get
kind of complicated um okay this is that
number there is probably the distance to
the center of the earth for the position
of the satellite and the sea
1 times 10 to the 7 yes it probably is
okay so what I'm gonna do here if I
really want to know how far away that
satellite is I'm really gonna let's
really get this right let's do this
and then in here I want to say radius of
Earth I'd sure I want to whoops I'm
gonna just use this quantity um okay
this is this is where how folks like me
try and actually work stuff out um all
right let's see that was the distance
there okay let's put that in this is so
this is going to give my position on the
earth and now I should be able to say
geo distance from my position on the
earth to the position that satellite had
at least when I asked for that position
which was a few minutes ago um see here
and okay
already works it out correctly okay it
already got that right
it was already calculating it based on
me being on the surface of the earth so
there's the answer um okay so the
question that was actually asked here I
think was what determines the accuracy
of GPS okay boy you guys are complicated
questions all right
okay the GPS satellites so one question
is when did your GPS receiver has to
work out how far it is to each of those
GPS satellites the way it does it is
actually a pretty clever the way it does
it is the GPS satellite is producing a
sequence of zeros and ones it's a very
particular sequence it is a what is it
called
huh shift register sequence yeah um
let's say that might not be that might
be too long let's do um okay the
satellite is producing a thing called a
shift register sequence and it actually
is producing one of these that's
millions of bits long and one feature of
this sequence it has a very interesting
mathematical property if I were to look
at some block of digits here that block
of digits only occurs once in the
sequence up to a certain length so it's
saying if if I see one zero zero one
zero one one I know where in this
sequence
I am so just by by seeing the block of
digits the piece of the the piece of
radio pulse that I see from the GPS
satellite I know we're in the sequence
of the GPS satellite I am okay so every
GPS satellite is sending out a shift
register sequence and those sequences
repeat let's see the longer ones repeat
every few months I think the shorter
ones repeat every day or two maybe but
within that time interval you can tell
exactly because there's a it's no one
it's it's every GPS receiver knows when
the GPS satellites are going to generate
a a particular part of that sequence so
they see oh
1 0 0 1 0 0 1 1 1 that means we are at
this particular part of the sequence
that means we are this particular
nanosecond in time relative to when the
sequence started because the sequence is
repeating that each bit is being
delivered at um takes
let's see around a few nanoseconds I
think corresponds to each bit now
actually I mentioned earlier the speed
of light is roughly 1 foot per
nanosecond so if you can tell how long
it took light to get to you from the GPS
satellite to within 1 nanosecond you can
tell where you are - within an 1
nanosecond by knowing if you know if you
can predict the orbit of the GPS
satellite so you know where the GPS
satellite is you know how far away you
were from 3 GPS satellites you know that
- within a nanosecond
- within a foot then you can triangulate
to work out your position within a foot
so in principle GPS can it's really
limited by how how fast these bits are
being transmitted and that's limited by
the radio frequency that's being used
and and so on but there are some other
limitations there are in fact for a long
time there was a thing called P mode GPS
the precision mode of GPS and the
precision mode of GPS was actually
blocked for a long time because it was
used for military purposes to be able to
have precise homing for things and the
civilian GPS was accurate only - no it
was 20 30 40 feet something like that um
the actually during during the Gulf War
was the first time that P mode GPS was
unblocked
um and the butt
then a few years ago the US Defense
Department decided to open up precision
GPS and so everybody can use it and that
term and that allows GPS receivers to to
know positions to within a few feet and
there's a thing called differential GPS
which tries to use the tries to kind of
use extra information from looking at UM
looking at differences between satellite
signals and things to work it out even
more accurately than that so that was a
that was a LAN so you guys ask
complicated questions but I think that
it was a fairly the it was a fairly
fairly decent answer to the is there a
maximum location accuracy the answer is
I believe it's ultimately limited by the
frequency of of this of these signals
being sent it is a good question whether
it is limited by the accuracy with which
we can predict the orbits of GPS
satellites and I'm pretty sure it's not
pretty sure that we can predict the at
the the satellite positions to really
very high accuracy there um okay let me
see you just go back here hold on one
second I'm I'm confusing myself ah there
we go okay we keep going here I just
have to rearrange my screen so I can see
what questions are asking um okay
is it true that all objects in Cuban
living things emit radio waves oh that's
interesting okay okay
what are radio waves radio waves are
otherwise known as electromagnetic waves
they are the result of whenever you have
a charge a piece of an electrically
charged thing like an electron electron
is the smallest unit of electric charge
and electric currents and wires and
things are made essentially from the
motion of electrons moving electric
charges through wires makes electric
currents whenever you movement whenever
you accelerate an electric charge it
will produce a radio wave it will
produce an electromagnetic wave now it's
a very tricky thing because there are
many ways to accelerate a charge so for
example one thing you can do is by using
voltage voltage is kind of the force
with which you're pushing electrons
through a wire for example and and
current is the number of electrons that
are flowing through the wire so as you
change the voltage you you you reverse
the voltage you keep reversing the
voltage you're pushing the electrons
like back and forth inside an antenna
and that will cause the electrons to
accelerate as they go the accelerating
one way then slow down they turn around
it's alright the other way every time
they accelerate they produce
electromagnetic radiation and so any
time there's an accelerating charge
there's electromagnetic radiation um the
okay for physicists okay so it's a
slightly fancier story okay math fact
it's actually X dot X triple dot rather
than X double dot squared is the is the
actual rate of radiation it just
produces some weird effects that let's
not discuss here
um but any case in a first approximation
the whenever there's an accelerating
electric charge it produces
electromagnetic radiation if it is being
accelerated and wiggled around at a
frequency of let's say a billion sort of
Wiggles per second it will produce
microwaves radio waves if it's if it's
wiggle the trillion times a second it
will produce visible light if it's
wiggled even much much faster than that
it will produce x-rays um but in general
anytime you sort of accelerate a charge
it will produce actually that radiation
okay the question is does that mean that
there is electromagnetic radiation
produced by produced in for example in
living organisms usually the answer I
think mmm it's a good question I mean
there's certainly a you know an electric
eel certainly succeeds in producing an
electric current and it succeeds in
producing electric radiation in kind of
the okay so sort of tricky fact is that
there are electrons that are being
whizzed around atoms those don't
normally produce terminal radiation if
you good question
do is there anything in us that in the
normal state of affairs will produce so
much more radiation
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm sorry
I'm not thinking straight
yes okay so whenever so the way our
muscles work okay the way our nerves
work they're sending electrical signals
so a nerve like we'll have a nerve fiber
that will go I don't know up you know
some part of way up our arm then there's
a repeater and then there's another
nerve fiber it goes our brain it goes to
our spinal cord then goes to our brain
and so on those are like little wires
and they are transmitting electric
signals and those electric signals
usually they're in little pulses maybe a
thousand times a second and the rate of
so for example when you when you touch
something the touch sensors in your
fingers are producing our little nerve
endings that produce that use
electrochemistry they use kind of
chemical processes to produce an
electric electricity that then flows
through the nerves and then our brains
detect that and inside our brains
there's there's lots of nerves that are
sending electrical signals all around
and that's kind of what our processes of
thinking consist
is those electric signals and all the
different interactions in the hundred
billion or so neurons nerve cells in our
brains so whenever we whenever we sort
of you know the way our muscles work is
we have nerves that go from our brains
and they go on our muscles and when an
electric signal comes from our brain
through the nerve when that electric
signal is is applied to the muscle
there's this protein called actin which
is a long filament type protein and when
that when there's a little electric
signal applied to that it will tense up
and that's what causes our muscles to
tense up and so what happens is that and
that electric signal so every time we
are moving out you know as I move my
arms around whatever you know what's
happening is an electric signal is going
from my brain and it's causing some
muscle the good the electric signal goes
to the actin filaments in my muscle
which is then tensed up and then causes
my my arm to move so that electrical
signal you can absolutely detect that
you can measure surgical M eg much that
stand for the in any case you can you
can measure electrical signals from from
the nerves when you tense up muscles and
things like this in fact in our brains
you can measure the electrical signals
in our brains that's what EEG is doing
electroencephalograph alog Rafi and we
can you know in our brains normally
there's there's these various rhythms
the neurons in our brains tend to tend
to sort of operate in a somewhat
collective way and so there's a rhythm
around nine point eight cycles per
second that is a big the Alpha rhythm of
the brain which is sort of a collective
collective electrical effect of our
neurons which we can detect by putting a
little electrons on our electrodes on
our on our head um and
so--that's and by the way there are
other electrical signals in humans like
the heart for example is a as a muscle
that's you know pumping blood and so on
and it is the the when it contracts and
so on sort of the signal to tell it to
contract comes from nerves that come
from the brain and they and you can you
can you can measure that you can also
measure the electrical activity
associated with the actual actually
you're mostly measuring in EKGs you're
mostly measuring the actual muscle the
effects of the article effects of the
actual heart muscle I think and that
again is another place where us humans
produce electromagnetic effects there
they're very I mean you have to stick
electrodes on yourself normally to be
able to detect that there are very
sensitive I mean there is there are
electrical signals that will be that
will be traveling through space you know
through through from us humans and for
example the magnetic analog of EEG you
can effectively detect that from a
distance although you have to be in a
very very place with very little
electromagnetic interference
um
okay I think we should we should wrap up
soon here but um let's see other
questions
let's see okay this
tation about the nature of scientific
thinking that'd be fun okay um something
to try alright um there's a question
here okay I'm gonna maybe two more I'll
answer one
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
somebody's asking what is plasma and
one is fairly easy let me do that one
and I'll do one more um the okay plasma
so normally there are three famous
states of matter phases of matter solids
liquids gases there actually are other
phases of matter that people don't talk
about quite so much that that for
example gels I mean for example we are
not obviously either solid liquid or
liquid with kind of mushy stuff and
that's kind of more like a gel and
that's a typical thing you get with long
complicated molecules that you don't get
with them with just sort of single
single atom kinds of materials and
things but okay plasmas are something
different
plasmas are what you get when you heat
up any material normally the atoms have
protons in the nucleus and so an atom
depending on its atomic number depending
on its atomic position in the in the
periodic table it will have some number
of protons so hydrogen has one proton
helium has two protons and so on in the
normal state of that the atoms the
number of electrons is the same as the
number of protons in the atom so
hydrogen ordinary hydrogen has one
electron one proton ordinary helium two
electrons two protons but you can do
what's called ionize these substances by
if you heat them up if you pump enough
energy into them you'll pull the
electrons away from the new place you'll
you'll be able to overcome the
electrical forces that hold the
electrons close to the nucleus and
you'll be able to tear them away and
then you'll have a so-called ionized
atom which doesn't have its full
complement or electrons and so that
ionized atom is what you have in a
plasma that's what you have in fire for
example it's what you have in the
surface of the Sun these are these are
these are plasmas that have that don't
have that have electrically charged
things in them not ordinary neutral
atoms you know when you have chemical
compounds the atoms also become ions but
the I
cancel themselves out so the whole
molecule can be electrically neutral but
the individual pieces like in a sodium
chloride table in ordinary salt that's
what happens it's na + CL - that's
because it's it's acting like one of
those things has an electron missing one
of those things has an extra electron
and that produces this force of
attraction that kind of holds the sodium
chloride together but when you heat
things up
you'll get atoms that aren't
electrically neutral that have their
electrons removed and they have all
kinds of weird properties they have all
kinds of properties about um the way
that they stop electromagnetic radiation
they stop radio waves things like that
kind of the most the most famous plasma
in a sense in the universe is the plasma
that used to be throughout the universe
back when the universe was very young
shortly after the Big Bang the whole
universe was hot enough that was all a
plasma and actually it stopped being a
plasma a hundred thousand years after
the beginning of the universe and so
back at the very very early parts of the
universe it was so hot that there
weren't just ordinary hydrogen atoms
there were separate electrons and
protons running around and it was
essentially a plasma of hydrogen gas and
so that meant that it was so one of the
consequences of that it was it was kind
of glowing like fire glows and it was
also you couldn't see through it like
you can't see through a piece of fire so
the that was so hundred thousand years
off at the beginning of the universe the
universe was all a non see-through
glowing plasma so question is what
happened to that plasma okay so this is
a okay let me so here's a question if
you look you know you know that it takes
light a certain time to come from let's
say a different star or different galaxy
like takes light eight minutes to get
from the Sun it take like light it takes
light for years to get from the nearest
other star Alpha Centauri
it'll take two
Oh like you know some other galaxy it
might take a million years for light to
get to us so as we look out in the
universe we see light that started its
journey towards us a really long time
ago and so one thing you might ask is if
you look out your notes and there's no
galaxies in the way and just look out to
the edge of the universe what do you
actually see well what you see is light
that came to us from essentially what
you're seeing is that plasma that
existed a hundred thousand years after
the beginning of the universe because
and it's a little bit the geometry is a
little bit complicated but essentially
the light that you see in any direction
comes from the comes from the the kind
of the the the reduced the the the kind
of cooled down longer wavelength version
of light that started from the plasma
that existed a hundred thousand years
after the universe began so in every
direction that we look out in in the
universe we see the kind of this thing
that's called the Cosmic Microwave
Background it started off as visible
light but because of the expansion of
the universe it's now turned into
microwave radio waves and we see in
every direction in the universe we will
see that that that that radio signal and
actually what happened that was
originally discovered in 1964 I think by
a couple of people at Bell Labs the
company that operated the u.s. phone
system the precursor AT&T the they they
were using satellites and things like
this early communication satellites and
they wanted to get they were they were
measuring the radio emissions and they
wanted to get really sort of low noise
radio emissions from their satellites
they were measuring you know how much
you know could they how how well could
they sort of listen to the radio signals
from the satellites and they were very
frustrated but
there was a background there was a radio
noise at very low intensity radio noise
at this very specific thing that
corresponds to a temperature of about
three degrees above absolute zero and
that they were sort of very frustrated
they just couldn't get rid of that radio
noise and eventually it was realized
that actually that radio noise is just a
feature of the universe it comes from it
is the sign of the of the it's the the
sort of signature of the Big Bang and
it's what we what we detect from that so
that was some no I'm forgetting what
question I'm even answering here gosh
that was terrible oh I was talking about
plasmas yeah I was saying that that's
the plasma that term the plasma from the
early universe the sort of last vestige
of that plasma is the Cosmic Microwave
Background
okay so last question I'm going to
answer here um the what's the likelihood
that there's another universe exactly
like ours out there that's a very
interesting question it's it
hard for us to know um let me tell you
something that really has surprised me
so let's imagine that we know the exact
laws of physics the exact rules that
determine how our universe works okay so
we know these exact rules we can you
know then we've solved the sort of
fundamental theory of physics we know
the rules for the universe we can say
this is how our universe works anything
we want to work out about a universe if
we had a big enough computer and big
enough might mean a computer bigger than
our universe which means we're out of
luck because we don't you know the best
we can do is use a computer that's in
our universe so we wouldn't actually be
able to work out what our universe will
do but at least in principle we'll be
able to work out what our universe would
do if we had a big enough computer even
though we couldn't actually have that
the computer that big but so if we know
the rule for the universe then we can in
principle work out everything about our
universe so then the immediate question
is okay we know the rule for the
universe and actually I'm I'm galloping
along getting close to being able to
find that rule and the okay so we know
that let's say we know the rule can we
you know hold it in our hands we put it
up on our computer screen here's the
rule you know it's some particular
mathematical like thing it's the rule
for our universe so the next question
we'd ask is okay why did we get this
rule why will we assign why was our
universe assigned this rule I mean there
might be an infinite number of other
possible rules why did we get this rule
and not another rule okay and I thought
that question will be unanswerable that
is I thought that there will be no
scientific answer to that question um
but I just had this sneaking suspicion
that there might be a scientific answer
to that question okay and his roughly
how it works and it turns out it looks
like there is an answer um the here's
the thing if you are an observer a
creature an organism a brain whatever in
the universe you are observing that
universe but the rules the laws of
physics that are governing how your
brain works are the exact same laws as
the laws that are governing how the
universe that you're
you're observing works so there's this
kind of funny interplay between you as
the observer of the universe being
governed by certain rules and the
universe that you're observing being
governed by the same rules and so I just
had this sneaking suspicion that it
might be the case that essentially every
universe every possible set of rules to
an observer who operates according to
the same set of rules will in a sense
look the same so if you were outside the
universe and you didn't operate
according to the rules of the universe
you would say oh this universe works
such in such a way but if you are
embedded in that universe
you might say of two different universes
two universes different rules you might
say oh those universes work differently
I can see that from the outside but if
you're embedded inside that universe
operating yourself according to the
rules of that universe you don't get to
see that you can't tell and actually
it's it's for physics types it's it's
similar to the way relativistic
invariance works and the the
independence of I can talk about seventy
some other time um but term in any case
so the surprise thing that I figured out
about a month ago actually is some that
it really looks like we're it there's
only one in other words all these
different possible rules that you might
use to describe the universe are all to
an observer within that universe all in
a sense looks the same so it turns out
that there's a bunch of footnotes to
this as a bunch more complexity to
exactly how this works but in some sense
every universe that works according to
rules that are even vaguely like the
rules of our universe is equivalent to
an observer in that universe to the
exact same universe so to my surprise I
think there's a scientific argument that
says there's only one universe now to
say there's an exact copy of our
universe yes we can't tell that we can't
tell the difference between those things
but to say oh there are different
universes and they operate according to
slightly different rules I think that's
not that won't work um now there is a
footnote to that and it's and for
another
and perhaps after I have a chance to
describe my whole big physics theory but
but the footnote has to do with what
kinds of computations can happen in the
universe and whether we can do hyper
computations and other such things I
think that's a topic for another time
and be really happy to talk about it and
you guys are asking such fun questions
I'm really you know I hope you find it
interesting and I hope well we're all
stuck um with them
that nasty twenty nine thousand base
pair sequence attacking us and trying to
replicate itself we can at least have
some fun
talking about science
so I'm I'd be happy to do another one of
these um I can talk about science I
could talk about technology and how some
technology could try and answer
questions about how various kinds of
Technology work and so on I will be
great to get some feedback from folks
who've been here to tell us what things
I was talking about that were just
boring incomprehensible you know kind of
what people were interested in and so on
um now on my effort to always do
something different that I've never done
before I'm actually going to do another
session on Thursday and it's going to be
about math and I'm going to try and talk
about fun with math and that will be
aimed at I think like let's say ten and
up folk I hope I have things to say that
will be a little bit surprising even to
people who are who know lots about math
but I I think I'm I'm going to I'm gonna
aim it I hope at um if you if you kind
of understand arithmetic decently well
you should be able to understand what
I'm talking about
and the UM
it's some so I will be doing that on
Thursday and I will try to try to
explain some fun things about math and
so um I hope you hope you enjoyed this I
had a good time and maybe I'll see you
all again I'll probably do another one
of these probably next week and as I say
math on Thursday okay thanks for joining
us and see you another time